how are you doing today sir
i'm good how are you man i'm doing
excellent um
i have to start with i think the most
important question um
when ryan murphy sets you up with a
great role
what's the thank you gift you get him
um doing good work i hope
um you know doing it justice um
rising to meet the occasion and
and and enjoying the experience and
coming from a place of gratitude for it
you know
um i don't know that
there's anything in the material world
that ryan murphy needs
um but uh but yeah it's uh it's a real
honor to be
a part of this company and to be a part
of his
initiative to amplify marginalized
voices and
tell diverse stories and i feel i feel
like this whole experience has been a
reflection of his commitment to that and
i feel i feel really honored to be a
part of it
100 i am a big fan of what ryan does
uh before i jump into your fantastic
work in this movie
um i've been asking everyone i've been
speaking to the last few months the same
three questions i promise they're
softballs
uh and so here we go um all right what
tv series would you love to guest star
on
succession i just interviewed jim and he
gave the same answer
oh really interesting interesting
um what movie have you seen the most
probably like almodovars movies
just in general like i sort of
cycled through his movies over time so
um
you know bad education
or all about my mother or talk to her
those three probably i just rewatched
them again in quarantine
um also magnolia a lot of paul thomas
anderson stuff
i love to revisit films that inspire me
like that
you know um so i'd say in that world
uh have you ever seen a tv show all the
way through more than once
no okay i'll leave it there
uh jumping into why i get to talk to you
um i cannot imagine
what it would have been like to see this
production off-broadway in 68.
have you ever sort of imagined being
back there and experiencing what this
would have been like
i mean i can only know what i've read
and talked to
people who were there but uh
you know what i've learned from them but
uh it was revolutionary it was
unprecedented it was
so significant a moment to
uh so i i don't i mean i think the only
thing i can equate it to
is something as as seminal as like you
know the
the passage of gay marriage um laws
you know like that that level of um
being validated uh as a member of the
lgbtq plus community i think
uh you know in 1968 it was probably on
par with that
just seeing yourself in a narrative um
probably was that impactful for people
who had up to that point lived
entirely on the margins and in the
shadows of
of mainstream heteronormative society so
i feel like it was a watershed moment
and uh and
um incredibly significant
i think about what the times were like
in 68
and i think about the fact that this
movie was made now
50 years later and it's going to be
released in 150 plus countries
around the planet same material and how
things have changed
um it has to mean a lot to you to be a
part of this
it really is and to be you know part of
this as a member of an
openly gay uh cast of
actors all of whom are thriving and
succeeding and
living in their own ways full
and authentic lives
it's an incredibly um humbling
uh company to be a part of it and and
when you mention all of the countries
that this movie is going to be released
in you know i don't think that they're
all
as progressive um as other parts of the
world and i think
it's it's um it's a kind of beacon
perhaps for young people in parts of the
world that don't feel as supported or
identified or seen in
the communities around them and and so
it's a particular honor to consider that
you know it was one thing to do this
play in new york and for all the people
who were able to make it
to the city and to make it to the booth
theater while we were performing
um it's great but i've heard from a lot
of people in my travels
in in the year and a half since we
finished the play in new york
um you know that they weren't able to
see it they weren't able to come
and and now we get to amplify the story
and put it out
um in a way that a place like only a
place like netflix could allow so i
think it's really particularly exciting
and
um and and humbling uh i also think that
a lot of young people
who take the freedom for granted um it's
you know an education to realize when
michael is going into the stairway and
he's dealing with his neighbors and
he's nervous about what they could think
what's going on in the apartment
the fact that they could call the police
and the whole i mean they could all
you guys could have all been arrested
how things have changed
absolutely and how it's easy to
um it's easy to take those changes and
um and not think about the sacrifices
that were made to ensure them
and i think a piece like this really
does connect audiences and particularly
younger audiences to
uh to those who came before
and those who had to endure the weight
of
um marginalization the weight of um of
persecution prosecution
in order that generations today
including mine
can enjoy um pretty unparalleled freedom
and integration i'm a big fan of bill
pope
and you worked with him on the film uh
can you share maybe a little bit about
what it was like working with him
bill's amazing i mean he's so talented
and uh and joe mantello
also an incredible director so the
combination of the two of them
you know i think joe brought to this
story
the sensibility of the production that
we collaborated on in 2018
on stage and and i think he worked with
bill
to translate the spirit of that
production into a cinematic language
um i think the two of them worked so
well together and
uh and and it's no it's no easy feat to
um to make cinematic uh a story that
takes place
in one room essentially um
you know with some some minor departures
outside
uh or upstairs but you know all by and
large this whole
this whole story takes place in at least
85 90
of it takes place in one location and so
for them to be able to
uh to to create an environment that's so
dynamic and so vivid and so cinematic i
think is a real testament to both of
their talent
i am still so curious what michael uh
wrote to harold
and uh i won't i'm out of time so i
can't ask you
um but perfect
hey listen uh great work thank you so
much for giving me your time
of course thank you good to see you
again